There exists in Dota a prestigious award.
A digital medal handed out to only the most heroic players.
The players who sacrifice themselves for the team.
The players who persevere through every hardship.
The players who feed incessantly and still make it out the other side.
That award is the Maelk award, and it is given only to players who do incredible things
in the face of unbelievable KDAs.
The Maelk award is somehow both an honor and a dig on the player that earns it.
It represents teamwork, sacrifice, perseverance and perhaps most importantly, incessant feeding.
It requires one player to go through a game with zero kills and at least 20 deaths, and then still somehow win.
It seems impossible, but this man did it.
“It’s fun, it’s great, they had their fun, we won the game, everyone wins, the meme
was created, the community wins.”
The Maelk award was born when this man, Jacob “Maelk” Toft-Anderson was playing on EG
in the ancient days of 2012.
Maelk was playing Position 4 for EG, and the team was still trying to get
their feet on the ground.
(Casting)
But it was the early days of Dota 2, and
it was a total wild west, and that meant that teams like the 2012 Mousesports roster could thrive.
"Hi, so how are you spending your time in Seattle so far if you're not gaming."
"Masturbating."
"Sorry?"
"So essentially we're playing this meme team from Mousesports, they have all these dumbasses on their
roster."
"How hard was that game?"
"It was probably close to my easiest game of my life."
"They have SingSing, they have Trixi, they have all these morons who don't know how to win in Dota."
"They know how to have fun though, and I respect that because gaming is ultimately about having fun
first and foremost."
"Alright thank you very much SingSing for coming on the show."
"Good luck in the future games and we'll see you later."
"Thank you thank you, I'm gonna go mastur-"
"F***ing SingSing"
But if mouz were memeing in the online joinDOTA Masters league, EG
were taking things seriously, they found themselves ahead in gold, but behind in XP in the
early game thanks to a few early kills from mouz.
(Casting)
And after scoring a few early
kills on Maelk’s Venomancer they thought it’d be hilarious to just keep killing him.
So they did.
(Casting)
Over...
And over...
(Casting)
While EG was farming well and maintained
a gold lead for most of the game, mouz still had the XP advantage,
and it was starting to matter a lot more.
(Casting)
By the end of the game, Maelk had died 20 times without picking up a single kill, but
it wasn’t for lack of trying.
While mouz decided it would be funny to keep killing Maelk, he was trying
to help his team win.
And even though he kept dying, sometimes he'd get the chance to pop his ultimate first.
Venomancer’s Poison Nova ability can’t actually kill anything.
It creates a ring of poison that spreads out and deals damage over time to every enemy
in it, but it leaves them at 1 HP.
That means even though Maelk dealt tons of damage to mouz, he never actually got any
kill credit for it.
But the rest of his team did.
(Casting)
It didn’t matter much though.
Both teams were kind of a mess.
EG were effectively playing with only four heroes, and while mouz were winning fights, they weren’t
winning hard enough to end the game.
"My first 10 deaths, some of them should have been avoided by me,
some of them was just good play by them. When we go into the later stages of the game,
by all means we should have lost. They had a full inventory Morphling,
they were decked out on all their heroes."
(Casting)
"They by all means should have won with the lineup they had."
"What they did though, they realized, 'Oh this guy has so many deaths, let's just see how many we can keep on
adding on to that.' You know I think at some point in the game some of them would write 'xD'
and sit and talk about how funny this was."
(Casting)
And so, after over an hour of play, EG decided it was time to keep forcing themselves
into mouz’s base until it stuck.
But not before Maelk died one more time.
(Casting)
And while Maelk may have died one last time, EG’s creeps finally managed to close out the game
after an hour and 26 minutes.
(Casting)
Maelk finished the game 0/20/21, and EG still managed to win.
That seems impossible but there's a few reasons for why it happened.
For one, mouz was really only focused on killing Maelk.
And another thing was that,
it was still the early days of Dota 2, and people just weren’t as good at playing
the game as they are now.
(Casting)
But the statline stuck.
It became an award.
The player who manages to go 20 deaths without a single kill and still win the game does
deserve recognition.
It’s mostly applied to amateur games, where players, casters and pros alike have witnessed
heroes who have bravely given themselves over to the Maelk Award’s hallowed halls of esteemed recipients.
"I've had a decent amount of years to sort of get used to it. I very rarely meet people for the first time without them
remembering that particular game, so I'm very used to the fact that people bring it up."
"I've also hosted, well not hosted but I've been on the desk in so many tournaments where my co-analysts keep bringing it up and finding it
amusing. When Paul was new to Dota 2 he also used it as a cornerstone of his mockery."
"And finally, last but not least, our panel wouldn't be complete without a star name. A former pro player
with expert knowledge and predictions, and a popular figure with the community.
Sadly, we could only get Maelk."
"I've had to grow some hard skin whenever that was brought up."
And Maelk himself is totally okay with the fact that his name is attached to what isn’t
exactly the most prestigious award in Dota history.
That’s probably because he won the game.
(Casting)
And honestly that’s what makes the Maelk award so impressive.
Maelk did more in death than he did in life.
And his team found a way to use the fact that he was dying so often
to their advantage.
Dota is unique among MOBAs in that deaths don’t matter as much as they do in a game like say,
League of Legends.
so you can actually make it back despite having a player on your team who has more
deaths than levels.
Dota is a game of teamwork, and that means that even if someone looks like they're feeding,
it might just be an elaborate plan concocted by their team to win.
Or they might be getting camped by some trolls.
Either way, they'll get an award for it.